[Music]
there's a special day that only comes
once a year where we honor the most
special lady in our lives it's not like
a regular mom I'm a cool mom I'm the mom
happy Mother's Day
hi I'm Deidre Behar come along as we
celebrate Mother's Day and run down our
favorite mother-daughter celebrity
doppelgangers happy mommy happy baby
North West definitely inherited her mom
Kim Kardashian's incredible style when
do people start telling you guys that
you look to like do you see you yeah
it's undeniable Kaia Gerber knows a
thing or two about twenty with her mama
Cindy Crawford so does Reese Witherspoon
her daughter Ava looks just like her
oh thank you oh my gosh she's gonna kiss
sweetheart Chrissy Teigen and little
Luna appear more alike every day Yolanda
Hadid z-- daughters Bella and Gigi have
followed in their mom's modeling
footsteps family is a big part of us
she's our favorite person in the whole
world oh my friend enroll amazing and it
seems one at Paltrow's little girl Apple
might have a career in showbiz - she
loves acting and singing and songwriting
Kate Hudson and Goldie Hawn have been
twinning and winning for years it's
pretty obvious Kate is super inspired by
her iconic mama everything she is it's
quite authentic and I think she's she's
such an original dark brown hair and
piercing blue eyes Katie Holmes and Suri
Cruise couldn't look more similar if
they tried she's a sophisticated little
girl and magical and whether it's
courtside at a red carpet or a music
video Beyonce and Blue Ivy brings some
serious swag
[Music]
happy Mother's Day tweet me your
favorite mother-daughter duo and
remember to shower your mom with all the
love she deserves you girls keep me
young uh I love you so much